Okay,
it's looking good here today with Gregg
Hurwitz,
who's a novelist and a screenwriter and
a comic book writer and a variety of
other things as well.
And uh,
we're going to talk a little bit about
his latest book,
the nowhere man,
and then we're going to talk to him
about writing more generally.
That's the plan anyways.
So how are you doing?
Great.
I'm doing well,
thank you.
So why don't you start by telling us a
little bit about your new book and then
about who you are.
Well,
my new book,
I started a new series with my last
book,
um,
and usually I write standalone
thrillers,
but my last book was based on,
uh,
I've,
I've sort of done a lot of really dumb
things in the name of research over the
years.
So I've gone undercover to mind control
bolts.
I've gone up and done airplanes,
I've snuck on a demolition ranges with
navy seals and blowing up cars.
And one of the things that kept coming
up when I dealt with a lot of the SPEC
ops guys were how these off the books
programs were implemented over the
years.
The sort of history beneath the history
that we're all aware of and I got really
interested in this and I thought about a
character who was taken out of foster
homes that the age of 12.
This is a program called the orphan
program and basically raised up to be
assassins to be their full training.
It's their full life and that's orphan
x.
that's the first book in the series.
And so in the second book,
the one that's just come out called the
nowhere man.
This acid is taken by somebody who
doesn't know who he is,
but want something from him and he's
taken off and spirited off out to this
remote chateau.
He doesn't know where it is and the
people don't know,
have no idea what his real identity is
or who he is.
And they think that he's trapped in
there with them.
And in fact they're trapped in there
with him and they're soon going to
realize that they have a major problem
on their hands.
And so it's the second and the folding
out of this new character.
His name is Evan Smoke.
So this is the first time that you've
written a series.
I know it's the second time you've
written a series,
is that right?
Yeah.
I heard a series early in my career and
then I went,
I've,
I went about nine books with Tiana loans
and then I returned to wet.
And part of that is,
it takes so long.
I mean the majority of my waking hours
I'm spending inside of manuscripting
with a character like I spend more time
with my characters who were fictional
that I do with my wife and kids.
And so it took me years to find your
characters or less complicated,
which is actually one of the themes of,
uh,
of the books.
Um,
one of the ways in which,
uh,
the complications that arise from
intimacy because my character was,
I was raised with the veil of
perfection.
You know,
a lot of the notions that I played with
him.
I came to when I was writing on,
on Batman.
I wrote Batman Comics for a couple of
years and there were some notions in
there,
the interest in me,
and one of them was the balance between
perfection and intimacy.
That was my main focus with Batman
because part of the reason why I liked
that man so much is you know he doesn't
have a magic ring light green lantern.
He can't fly like superman.
He's just a human who represents the
pinnacle of what can be accomplished
through sheer discipline.
But part of why that works is his
parents are dead.
He's not married,
he has no kids.
He lives up in Maine,
in Wayne Manor,
and he's completely undisturbed by
everyone and everything so we can hone
it.
And the more that you let people into
your life and the more that you allow
intimacy in your life,
the more complications come.
That sort of detract from this previous
notion of perfection.
I've got a question about that.
So that seems to me to reflect in some
sense the problem,
maybe the different problems or maybe
the different orientation of of men and
women.
So it's possible for men too,
and I think many men can do this too,
is to sacrifice everything,
including intimacy to become really good
at one thing.
Whereas women,
as far as I can tell,
and of course this is a broad
generalization and one that will
undoubtedly get me in trouble,
we would never get in trouble.
No,
no.
I know women are,
I think more concerned with intimacy and
relationship.
And that's an interesting dichotomy that
you established between those two.
And so what,
why you said that intimacy detracts from
perfection because it's sort of,
it spreads you out in the world.
Why did you come across that particular
paradox?
Why do you think that one fascinates
you?
Well,
I'm,
I'm hyper
and one of the things that I noticed is,
and I think that's the thing,
when you find a character who you need
to live with more than you do with your
family,
you have to find something at the heart
of them that's uniquely compelling.
And for me,
I think I have.
I have a strong perfectionist drive and
as I've got when I was younger,
it served me well,
right?
A lot of the traits that we have or
negative traits that might be survival
instincts that got us through a key
period of our life,
um,
they're easy to discard when they're not
helpful.
Right?
So like,
if you can have a bit of a temper,
it's easy to get rid of it.
The ones that are really hard or
adaptive,
you know,
qualities that we have that have gotten
us very,
very far.
But now we're starting to interfere with
our lives.
And so one of the things that I noticed
is that my drive for severe discipline
and perfection,
uh,
is tough when you're married,
when you have a wife,
when you have two kids,
when you have a dog,
if you're singularly focused,
but it's also not something that the
answer is to just give up completely,
you know.
So it's trying to find a of maintaining
the value and the drive and the
discipline that's necessary to be a
novelist and a screenwriter and comp
writer and,
and also the exhibit discipline in other
areas of my life,
while also a lab allowing for sort of
the complications that come with
intimacy.
And so with Evan Smoke,
with my main character,
for me,
the whole series coalesce around a
certain exchange that he has,
which is,
you know,
one of the things that I did when I
first was thinking about him being
pulled out,
he's this broke foster kid,
pulled out of the projects in East
Baltimore at the age of 12 and he's
raised only by handler.
No one even knows who he is and his
codings or fanatics.
And I thought instead of making this the
usual Sabi backstory,
what if that handler was a really
fundamentally good man and became like a
father figure and actually loved him.
And at one point Jack Johns,
who's his handler,
tells him the heart when he's a kid.
He says,
the hard part is not going to be making
you a killer.
The hard part is gonna be keeping you
human and forever and the thing that
stuck in my head was it would be so much
easier if he was just purely as an acid,
if his moral compass was never broken,
but because of the way that he was
raised,
he at a certain point,
the ambiguity's of committee,
these assassinations in different
territories where we're not supposed to
be and he has limited information that
the moral ambiguity is become too much
and he leaves and become sort of a pro
bono assassin for people in desperate
need.
Like that's where we meet him in the
series and it's only because Jack had
gave him a human connection that opened
up the complexities that make this
complicated for him.
You know,
when I was writing the punisher is a
marvel character.
That's not hard.
The punishers families,
all dad,
he just wants to kill everybody.
He wants to punish everybody.
With Evan,
there's this thing at the heart of it
that like he still has to function with
this humanity that was given to him from
his father figure.
Right.
I was thinking that of the Batman movie
with Heath Ledger,
and one of the things that happens in
the movie is that the joker accuses
Batman of being exactly the same as he
is fundamentally like there you could
say opposite sides of the same coin or
maybe even closer than that.
And it seems to me that there's
something in what you're saying that
mitigates against the deadly danger,
maybe even what you call it,
a psychopathic intensity of single
mindedness because one question you
might ask yourself is that if,
if,
if intimacy interferes with perfection,
then why bother with it?
Probably not,
right.
And well,
and also like how do we widen out the
definition of perfection?
It's like,
okay,
so if you take Bruce Wayne to his
logical end and he's,
you know,
killed a lot of bad guys and maintain
fit physical perfection,
uh,
and dies alone in his manner is that
actually perfection.
Like you have to broaden our definition
of what you apply perfection to.
And um,
I didn't
do as good a job of laying out that
dichotomy in my earlier question.
I might've,
but one of the things you mentioned was
that it was his presupposition that men
were after perfection and women were
after wholeness.
That's a more inclusive than the issue
with perfection is,
but it's single minded,
right?
And that only focuses on,
let's say one thing,
whereas wholeness seems to be something
more like the balance between a variety
of,
uh,
positive and valuable things.
And you can't be perfect at a variety of
useful and balanced are valuable at
balance things you have to settle for
maybe b plus at a,
at a variety of them.
But the question is,
is the totality ethan more valuable than
perfection along one axis?
And I suppose it depends on the
situation,
but,
but obviously that's something that
you're continually toying with and you
said it because it reflects a similar
situation in your own life and with your
own character.
So you,
you've managed to integrate intimacy
into your life.
And so what's been the advantage to
that?
Well,
the advantage is it's,
I mean,
a lot of the things that give that
ultimately give I think pleasure and
meaning to life come from intimacy.
You know,
it's that thing,
it's like there's the old saw that
people say when people die,
it's rare that they're going to say,
Gosh,
I wish I worked more in regardless of
what the work is versus spending time
with your family and with your friends.
And it's like I've noticed increasingly
as I get older,
there's a shift in priorities and
values,
but it stills one that's,
it's hard for me at times because I get,
I can get single minded.
I mean I can get hypo manic when I'm
writing.
I write generally 10 hours a day,
but I've written as much as 23 hours
straight,
you know,
when I was on a TV show that was a risk
of shutting down and we needed a script
and there's just not a choice for it.
So I can get incredibly focused.
But the more focused that that I get
with writing,
one of the things that you're doing with
writing when you're in a venture that's
difficult is you have a very high error
recognition,
um,
alarm system,
right?
That's cliche.
That's not gonna work that's been seen
before.
And you want to do something that's new
and if you're in a field that's hard,
that's turned up really high,
well that can make living with you
really difficult or interacting with
other people.
Very effective for work to say,
how do I make everything better?
What's everything that's wrong with
this?
It's sort of an approach to a
manuscript,
but it doesn't work as well if you have
a two year old or a five year old at
home where you're trying to to to deal
with something else and you can also
lose perspective.
So there's a,
there's a single mindedness to the range
of perfection that you can lose things
at the periphery.
So like having some pe pluses and other
arenas I think are better.
I mean that's one of the things what
relationships are good for is literally
providing perspective.
Like we always say that,
you know,
my friend gave me a good perspective,
but it's like there's somebody literally
outside you looking at you aware of what
your blind spots are aware of the things
you're doing wrong,
but we just can't see.
And that's one of the intimacy is
immensely useful is it's like you can be
on perfection and just tell often,
but wilderness and be gone if you don't
have other people looking at you and
keeping you human,
you know.
And so it's.
Right.
Well that's actually one of the
arguments that I've been making up here
as you know,
for the necessity of freedom of speech
is that it isn't so much that you get to
say what you think and be right.
It's that you get to say what you think
and be exposed to the corrective views
of other people and they have the same
responsibility and right with regards to
their own speech,
they have to say what they think,
but they have to be open to corrective
input from other people.
Well,
and,
and it's,
it's impossible.
Like if we want to evolve into a society
where if you misspeak,
like for instance,
there was a Saturday night live writer
who made it a tweet that was denigrating
Barron trump,
right?
And she ultimately regretted it,
And so she apologized.
Doesn't matter,
sign out,
live kind of a suspended,
are either suspended her or let her go,
suspended her indefinitely and so
there's this interesting question of
like if you're a comedian and your job
is to be funny,
being funny revolves on being a reverend
and on being surprised and you're the
court jester in a certain way.
You have to go too far sometimes in
order to do your job properly and maybe
that's three times out of 10.
So she said something that she believed
that she went too far and she apologized
for us and we've gotten into this place
that people don't accept apologies
anymore
worse.
Actually,
I think it looks to me like we've got to
a place where if you,
if you make an apology,
people regard that as a final proof of
your guilt.
Right?
Which it.
Yeah.
And then it encourages a lack of insight
and apology from people who are
increasingly rise in power.
But the thing for me that so interesting
is it's like when I write,
I give myself permission to write a
vomit draft of a book.
I talked to so many aspiring writers who
say,
I sit down and I just walk up,
I write a paragraph and then I don't
know what to do.
I've conversation after conversation
with people and I say,
don't be afraid to make mistakes and
fail.
You cannot fix a blank page.
Get something down.
I call it the vomit draft and then you
can fix it.
And if we're losing that ability in
speech like everyone has to speak like
Winston Churchill upon first pass
everyone else a perfectly constructed
sentences perfectly regarding thought.
We're going to lose our ability to
interact in ways that are meaningful to
stop and pause and say,
you're right that,
that did go too far.
Let me back off.
Yeah.
Students,
my graduate students and my
undergraduates as well to write a really
bad first draft.
And I also tell them,
you can't play around with that.
Like you can't pretend that you're going
to write a really bad first draft and
then uh,
and then you know,
break the rules of that game and rights
and tried to write something good
anyways because that doesn't work.
It doesn't free you up and you know,
I tell them that at the same time if
they're trying to write a 2000 word
essay to write a really bad 3000 word
essay or 4,000
word essay so that they can feel
comfortable throwing away 50 percent of
it and
amazing how you get to good through
that.
Like a lot of times I sit down,
uh,
you know,
and if you're not feeling it,
and if I just start writing at a certain
point,
it's sort of like if you set.
I always tell young,
younger writers set time that you make
sap percent.
You know that as above all else that you
have to.
Right?
So even if it's an hour twice a week,
at a certain point,
you're going to hit the hour mark and
realize that you're at an hour and a
half years at an hour and 45 minutes.
It leads to more.
And so if you're willing to write into
mistakes and errors and not be overly
concerned with,
you know,
if everything is an impeccable he
detailed,
you will get to stuff that's better.
At a certain point you'll start doing
real writing.
The language will start to actually be
alive as opposed to dad.
It's a way to,
to access it.
It's like a warm up jogging,
a warm up clamp on a track before you
sprint and we need to be able to have
that,
you know,
and it's,
you have to push yourself out to the
place where you're actually making
errors.
You were talking about comedians and it
seems to me that that's,
if you're exploring a set of new ideas,
instead of just writing down what you
already know,
which would sort of be like imitating
yourself or parodying yourself,
you have to push yourself past what you
already know.
And if you're not doing that,
if you're doing that,
you're going to make mistakes.
And if you're not doing that,
then you're not going to be doing
something that's creative and
interesting.
And so there is some kind of,
excuse me,
but there is some kind of optimal ratio
of error to creative thought.
I remember that there was a good study
done about relationships,
um,
and their longevity.
And one question might be,
how many positive interactions compared
to negative interactions do you have to
have an order for a relationship to
maintain itself stably across time and
you'd think,
well,
the higher the positive to the negative,
the better.
But that isn't how it turned out.
It turned out that five positive to one
negative interactions,
roughly speaking was the lower bound.
If it got,
if the negative,
if the ratio God lower than that,
then people got unhappy in the
relationship degenerated,
but if it got above 11 positive
interactions to one negative
interaction,
it also became unstable.
And I think the reason for that is that
there is no corrective information.
Yeah,
that's a tough one for people to grasp
because they often don't get to
contentment,
but is it content that exactly?
Or is it spaces or.
Or it's also there's something horrific
about only seeing the positive reflected
back to you.
It's
take things for granted.
I always,
I always say about blocks.
It's like when I'm writing any project,
if there's not a certain point that I'm
scared that I can't pull it off.
I haven't chosen the right project.
I mean,
and I'm,
I don't know,
18 novels in,
I mean I've written 10 scripts,
I've written 80.
Um,
and part of that is how to change things
up and this whole notion that we're
talking about with,
with this character,
with them and smoke started with that.
I was like,
I was thinking about writing this ultra
bad ass assassin character.
It's a thriller or deals with other
themes,
some of which we can get into.
But part of what I thought about was,
you know,
we never see.
We never see James Bond go home.
We never see Jason Bourne and a bad ass
mission.
He's bleeding in his arm and he gets in
an elevator with a single mom who is an
elderly woman who's a neighbor in the
nagging him to go to his homeowner's
association meeting because you haven't
done it yet.
So it's like,
if I can create a character who
represent these archetypical ideals,
but crossing in the world with me and
you,
no one's done that.
And the whole time I was writing that,
I was thinking,
is this going to just fail miserably?
Is this not going to interest people and
my birth because we're using,
you know,
anyone who's writing genre,
we're using a previous mole,
which I don't,
I don't mean in a way that's
denigrating.
I mean,
that's what,
that's what Shakespeare,
Dan,
you know,
some of the,
the destructuring containment and
traditions of reform form can be
enormously useful.
But I'm always trying to tap it and
break it at the edges.
I did that a lot when I was writing
Batman.
So.
So let's talk about the comics and bit.
You wrote Batman for hold on
two,
two years.
I started writing six months of the pain
boy,
um,
and I had this really funny thing.
I was writing for marvel or Wolverine
and punish her or her,
two of my favorite characters and dc
came along and told me I could do sort
of whatever I wanted and you know,
pick a character.
And I said,
what I really want to do is write a
graphic novel of the pain Goin.
And he sort of looked at me with alarm
because of all the choices that I had.
That was totally bizarre.
But one of my big inspirations and
comics is the killing Joe by Alan more.
That's the the essential origin story of
the joker.
And I thought the pain one had always
been kind of a joke.
And furthermore I thought how
interesting,
because if you're the penguin then
Batman is the enemy at that man is a
bully.
Right?
And so I wanted to do this alternate
thing and so he was like,
you know,
the Polisher dc let me do it.
But I still remember there was an online
poll that said that they listed 10
upcoming comics,
mind among it and asked how much readers
work.
We're anticipating them.
And I got point,
oh,
three percent of the vote.
And I still remember one of my favorite
denigrating comments of all time is one
guy just wrote,
I'm so glad her,
his mom voted for him,
which was great.
And so he came out to like the interest
of no one.
But what happened is,
is that the critics really spoke to us
and then readers really sparked to it
and people all of a sudden said,
we've never looked at the pain when this
way.
And it was this very interesting object
lesson that like,
had I gone for the obvious and said,
let me write Batman right away,
or let me write superman right away.
I chose something that was super bizarre
that I had to write.
And then I knew that I really wanted to
write and could do well and from the
most unlikely position it led to me
having,
it sort of led to a whole other phase in
my career,
you know?
And then I found myself,
you know,
all of a sudden I'm working on Batman
for two years with the best artists in
the world.
But
he took a,
he took a lowly approach and an approach
to something that people actually phoned
contemptible
Yes.
And,
and,
and through that you got what you want.
So what in the world wasn't about the
penguin and the story that you wrote,
the why in the world.
Did the Penguin grip you like that?
Do you have any idea,
and tell us again,
tell us what you made of it as well.
Well,
I,
I had a strong affinity,
like I said,
for the killing joke and I always
thought the pain one was so interesting
because of all of Batman's rivals.
He's the only one who's saying that
right of the hole,
you know,
of all of the nemeses.
And the other thing that just really
struck me was this whole way to view
Batman through completely different
prism.
I mean like you can look at the joker
who's insane and then you look at
Batman,
but,
but that means semi insane too,
like there's craziness and it's such an
interesting prism.
So with the pain one I wrote about his
upbringing and you know,
he's this unappealing overweight kid.
His brothers were,
you know,
athletic and robust.
He was always bullied growing up.
And it's like,
well guess what Batman is.
That means like this paragon of a
physical specimen.
So he's always appearing in the
background.
But I was like,
if I can get people to empathize with
the penguin and view Batman is a villain
or not as a villain necessarily,
but just to really,
if we can really relate to the penguin
and what his position is in that
universe.
Um,
I just thought that would be cool.
But also a lot of it was.
And Alyssa lot what happens is like,
I don't have a conscious thought about
it.
I was literally driving to the meeting
with the publisher dc and I just was
thinking,
I know the story,
I know how to write it.
I know how I want to sort of directed on
the page.
I know what I want to say with that.
And it's only in hindsight I can look
back and untangle it and realize that,
you know,
oh,
well,
part of what I was interested in were,
were,
was the aspect that it's,
that he's actually saying and there's a
bullying way.
And it's a way to look at that man
through a new.
Yeah.
Well,
there's a,
there's an interesting idea lurking in
there as well,
which is,
if you think of Batman as an,
as an ideal,
now he's kind of a one dimensional
ideal.
An ideal is also a judge because it's
something that you can't attain exactly
or,
or that if you look at it,
um,
makes you acutely aware of your,
of your lack,
and so on the one hand that ideal is
something that is positive and we're
striving for,
but on the other hand it's necessarily
something that's got this.
It's not exactly a bullying element,
but it's something similar to that
because you're insufficient in its
presence,
might say as well,
to the degree that the ideal is one
dimensional.
The fact that you're insufficient in its
presence is actually a bit.
It's a bit unjust or unfair because
there may be other dimensions of
comparison along which you're,
you're doing fun.
It's actually a claim that's quite
similar to the postmodernist idea.
You know that if you erect a hierarchy
of values,
then by necessity you exclude people
from that hierarchy and that that is in
some sense it's oppressive and it's
wrong.
Of course they issue,
they don't address is that if there's no
hierarchy of values,
there's nowhere to go and there's
nothing to do,
but there is a point there that if
you're the exemplar of something you
make everyone else feel insufficient in
your presence and you could also imagine
it would be easy for that to take on a
bullying aspect.
I still focused a lot on the villains
and their perspective,
so I did it with David Finch on Pearl
Harbor Event and for the new 52 and then
I did one with the mad hatter with with
Eaton Vance,
skype or some of these amazing artists.
But one of the things that I put
in one of the comics is one of the thugs
who batman comes along and says like,
you don't remember when you do you have
that meant says no,
and you guys,
you came flying through the window and
you know the typical Batman scene and
kick me with your,
you know,
your,
your boots leaned on my jaw.
Here's what that surgery was.
Here's what I'm living with.
And he goes down this very detail
because so often it's Batman swings
through window and smashes a bad guy and
we all move on and I took these pauses
sometimes to kind of look at things from
a different angle and it was horrific
and fractured his skull and his,
you know,
his sinus was out and it was this
horrific injury that took,
you know,
15 screws and I sort of detail of the
whole thing as he throws it back to
Batman to be like,
you know,
I'm,
I'm kind of cannon fodder and your
mission,
maybe what I was doing is wrong.
Here's the level of pain that you've
inflicted on me nonetheless.
And it was this interesting pause and
I'd say the things that.
There's always a tightrope act when
you're writing a comic book character
because they're sort of in a public
trust.
You know,
I don't own them.
DC doesn't fully own them though.
They owned them legally.
But like the stuff that you know,
that you can't do,
you can't have Batman and kill a bus
load of nuns.
I mean there's the obvious.
But part of what they hire me is it's
like I need to bring something new to
this character,
but also I need to honor the traditions
that have come before.
So it's like I've been entrusted with
this thing where I have to play with it
and I have to navigate that tight rope
very,
very meticulously to do something that
makes it worth them bringing me on to
give readers something new and to make
myself feel like I've put my own stamp
on the character but not stray too far.
So it's a real exercise in being this
sort of,
you know,
holding the flame of this tradition.
One of the ways I did that a lot too,
that,
that did was I would make fun of the
tradition itself.
I got slightly mete with it,
for instance.
So it gives you.
One example is I did a scene where Jim
Gordon,
the police commissioner is talking,
you know,
it's late at night.
Batman appears in his office.
They're having a conversation,
it's darkly lit.
And Jim starts to muse on something and
he walks,
you know.
So the frame is just with him and he's
looking out the window and he talks for
two panels.
Then he says,
oh,
this is the part where I turned around
and you're no longer there,
right?
And there's a blank,
and then Batman says,
nope.
And then they turned around and regard
each other very awkwardly for a panel
and then they go,
all right then.
And then they will walk away awkwardly.
So it's like it.
It's knowing that we all live in a world
of Batman comics and maybe Batman
himself even does also.
And some of those little nuances are,
or a way to kind of massage,
massage it into something in,
in a culture that's increasingly pop
cultural where.
So,
so I was thinking about this perfection
issue again and the issue of
monstrousness.
So I read this,
I think it was a billion wicked
thoughts,
which is a very interesting book of the
Google engineers were looking at google
searches and trying to do psychology as
a consequence.
And because they're engineers,
they're,
they'll think anything they want to
think and they don't care much about how
politically correct it is.
For example.
And one of the things they noted was
that they were looking at pornography
use and it's no surprise to anyone,
of course the men use images for
pornography fundamentally,
and everyone knows what the images are
like.
It's,
it's,
it's usually young women who are
symmetrical and so forth and,
and youthful from associate biological
perspective because that's associated
with a fruitfulness and fecundity and
that sort of thing.
And,
and,
and
that's actually my favorite website is
young women who were symmetrical not
call the advertisement has to be
slightly different,
but nonetheless point is taken.
Yes,
exactly,
exactly.
They also looked at female pornography
use and that surprisingly enough,
and it was almost all literary it was
written and it was stories and they
pointed out.
But the basic story,
and this is something that I found
extremely useful because in some ways
I'm,
I've always been looking for the
fundamental female myth,
um,
because it's not exactly the same as the
hero archetype,
which is perhaps the fundamental male
myth.
But anyways,
the female myth was essentially beauty
and the.
So the guy was basically obviously,
and she would,
she would entice him into a relationship
that would tame him in some sense and he
would become humanized but under her
tutelage and devote himself to her and
they named the five most common beasts
in this kind of literature be soft
corporate Augie or maybe even hardcore
pornographic literature.
I know that even a Harlequin,
the big purveyor of romance novels has a
pretty hardcore side imprint.
Anyways.
The five most popular beasts were
surgeon,
billionaire,
pirate vampire,
and we're wolf,
which is,
you know,
really quite comical as far as I'm
concerned.
But it made me think,
well you were talking about perfection,
that there is a kind of monstrousness
imperfection as well.
And so,
you know,
again,
women,
they,
the research evidence seems to suggest
that women made across and up dominance
hierarchies where men mate across and
down socio economic dominance
hierarchies.
And so the women are in some sense
attracted to guys who are unit
dimensionally monstrous enough to climb
to the top of a given dominance
hierarchy.
But then,
and so that begs the question,
which is that in that drive for
perfection,
if there isn't something intrinsically
monstrous and that has something to do
with the willingness to sacrifice
everything else to that single minded
pursuit.
So I wonder if those things are even if
you can even take them apart because
Batman who's obviously a creature of the
night,
I,
I would say he's probably the superhero
that has the most self evident
integration of pathology associated with
his character,
something like that because he's this
dark guy and he definitely operates
outside of the parameters of the law
quite clearly and is motivated to know
small and by vengeance I would say like
the end,
the borderline between vengeance and
justice is of course very murky.
So then you talked about the,
the,
the requirement or the utility of
intimacy in buffering against that
perfection.
But that makes you wonder too if it also
provides a necessary buffer against
monster business.
Well that's to the hard part than
turning into a killer and the hard part
of keeping you human
and that that's the law that he deals
with.
But I can say,
you know,
with,
with orphan x,
I mean this is a book that connected
with readers.
It's been translated and published in 20
languages.
The vast majority of emails that I get
or about his relationship trying to
navigate way through the normal world.
That's the stuff that people love with
it.
So there's the mission,
there's the spy stuff.
I'd say there's two parts.
One of them is that he is a trained
assassin who now is become a pro.
Bono was asset.
His moral compass was never broken
because of his upbringing with Jack.
He now helps only the truly desperate
orals to turn evil capitalist.
Exactly.
Well he has.
He has money stash and bank accounts
everywhere for when he was operating off
the books.
So there,
there's a,
there's a good capitalist string still
going on.
But the other thing is these
interactions,
like you know,
there's a single mother who's been
widowed with a young boy who lives
downstairs from him,
who he is,
who he is in amherst have but has no
idea.
He doesn't speak the language of
intimacy.
So there's this like distant flirtatious
relationship with her.
The boys very enamored of Evan,
he doesn't quite know what to do with
her to complicate matters further.
She's a district attorney,
so she actually knew anything about him
that's legitimate and she'd have to
prosecute him and those,
those moments of him trying to figure
out,
I'm,
I'm carrying out this mission that
requires comprehensive discipline and
focus and yet here's this draw to this
woman and her kid and they'll kind of
warmth of a house that's,
that's an immense draw for him and I
think at the heart of him,
there's this conflict where like I
always,
I view it.
Then he's kind of got his face up to the
glass and he's looking at it.
All of these people leading ordinary
lives that he himself could never leave.
Like he can never live those lives.
But so what he can do is to protect
people when those ordinary lives are
disrupted and when they're put upon by
horrible men.
Right?
Are horrible.
Unfixable solutions.
The cops can't help you.
Nobody can help you and you're
powerless.
You've been bullied nearly into oblivion
and there's a huge risk to yourself.
They can call him and he can fix it so
we can constantly reestablished and
protect the lives of other people,
but he can't ever have that and so that
for me is what's really interesting and
that takes a twist in the knower man,
as we discussed,
which deals more with kind of different
thematics since he's the one who's
captured about aging versus you know,
about trying to be everything versus
trying to be one thing.
Yeah.
You played that out differently in the
nowhere man was different.
Yeah.
That's it.
That's a slightly different theme,
right?
That's,
there's a peter pan theme there.
Yeah,
go ahead.
No,
no,
go ahead.
Well,
so I mean,
so again,
in the nowhere,
man,
I mean for the second book,
it's always tricky to follow up a book
that,
that connects with the readership in a
certain way,
but I really wanted to turn reader
expectations on their head.
So I thought,
well,
what if instead of of avid going and
doing another mission that we're used
to,
he gets the anonymous phone call and
goes and help someone.
What if he finds himself in exactly the
kind of predicament that other people
usually call him before,
so the no,
Amanda opens with him and finishing out
the end of an operation somehow manages
to get kidnapped,
as I mentioned.
He comes to in this distant chateau
where he's being overseen by a guy
called Renee Peter casserole and we're
not quite sure why he's there.
They don't know who he is.
Yes,
things are going to get really bad.
There's dozens of armed guards,
but ever now is the one who he would
normally call and has to free himself,
so it's about his own liberation to get
back to finishing the mission that he
wants to do and to protect other people
were at the chateau.
But what was interesting to me is that
conversation that we seem to always have
in in thrillers and mysteries and
comments.
You're just like me,
I'm.
Renee has a similar thing to have and it
says like me,
you don't have any rules.
He knows he's a vigilante,
doesn't quite know what he does,
but he thinks he's might be a drug
dealer or you know,
an arms dealer.
He's,
he's ambiguous,
he's really just after a particular bank
account that evidence attached to it
hasn't yet learned to realize and Evelyn
says,
no,
you want to be everything.
I want to be one thing.
Well,
and it occurred to me when I was doing
that.
So Peter,
Renee,
I'm sorry.
Renee.
Peter Cassar.
Roy casserole is a play on the French
word for Pan,
so it's sort of read a Peter Pan.
He's,
he's,
he's obsessed with luxury,
with being all things with,
with not making choices,
with turning back the clock on aging.
He takes a regimen of pills he's
obsessed with,
with the aging process.
And it occurred to me again after I
wrote it,
because I don't go in charting these
things out like an engineer.
I go in writing a story that I want to
write,
but it occurred to me that Evan
statement to say were as different as
can be.
You want to be everything.
I want to be one thing.
Well that being one thing,
well is our only antidote really to
aging.
So it's the exact opposite of what renee
is trying to do.
Who's
the antidote to remaining that?
That it's the antidote to to becoming an
old child to which is of course it
depends story,
right?
There's this idea that you have to give
up everything to become one thing and
it,
but if you don't give it up,
then you become no thing eventually
because aging drives.
Maybe that's also why your character
casserole,
right?
Has to find off aging because aging is
forcing him to become well at,
if not to become one thing,
at least to lose his capacity to become
anything or everything.
Exactly,
and that's the only thing that,
that that's your board.
I mean that's the other argument to
perfection versus intimacy.
At some person,
at some point,
the toll of aging takes perfection away
from us in every way.
If you're a sharp shooter,
if you're an athlete,
if you're young Paul Newman and look
like young Paul Newman,
who is probably the best working human
humanum,
either gender in history at some point,
no matter what,
you are a perfect app,
you're a great surgeon.
Perfection will be taken from you.
So well,
what's the antidote to that?
They ended up to that doing something,
doing something else.
Well at making choices.
Are you a good husband?
Are you a good father?
Do you have a good.
Yeah.
Well that community around you and your
friendships around you so that when an
agent comes and starts to kick out those
stilts,
you have enough under you that you're
just topple over.
Yeah.
Right.
Well,
so that's interesting because the.
You talked about the necessity for,
for uh,
for perfection as an antidote say to the
Peter Pan Problem,
but what the case you're making now is
more of that even perfection as an
antidote to the Peter Pan Syndrome has
its problems,
but maybe those aren't echoed with
intimacy and you know,
because you talked about getting older
and the fact that your family and
friends become more important to you,
which is definitely something that I've
noticed.
Um,
and
I guess on your death bed,
let's say,
okay,
one of the things that's going to matter
is who's around there with you?
Right?
And I.
and as you get older and you get robbed
if things.
I wonder if it's the intimate
relationships that you have to provide
solace with regards to that.
I mean,
one of the things that distresses me
about the way that our world,
the modern Western world is unfolding is
that we act as if we're never going to
be any older than 35 young talked about.
Carl Jung talked about that he thought
it was a flaw in our founding myth
because if you think about Western
culture is predicated on Christianity.
Of course Christ died when he was about
32.
That's the.
That's the theory and so there's not
necessarily any model there for moving
into the latter house of life and there
is this obsession in western culture
with youthfulness and with the
possibilities of youth and people.
People Act,
I would say is if they're never going to
get old,
and so they.
One of the dangers there is that you
don't establish the kind of
relationships that are going to buttress
you in your old age.
You ended up finding a sample in your
forties or whatever and it starts to get
pretty ugly.
It loans
in La because La is the land of the
perpetual adolescence,
right?
Everyone comes out here off their
proverbial bus from Des Moines or
northern Alberta and they want to make
it.
They're the best looking person from
their hometown and who started their
hometown play and you know,
it's squeezing the universe through a
funnel for people.
We're actually going to be a movie star,
actually going to make it as a singer,
but it's sorta this intermittent
reinforcement thing that happens is it's
like they'll go two or three years
working on jobs because they need to
keep their schedule open for auditions
and then they'll get cast as an extra in
one thing and then they go three or four
more years because,
you know,
because at any point you could hit the
lottery and everyone has the story of
the,
you know,
the guy who was a,
know our,
our culture is also built around never
give up,
right.
You know,
follow your dreams.
And there's,
there's,
there's a pervasive notion that you
never settle.
Um,
and,
and I'm not denigrating those things.
I'm saying that that's part of our
culture is built,
but you see a ton of people here in
their forties,
fifties who never sort of moved onto a
job or a scaled.
It's gratifying there.
Their whole life has been spent waiting
for another break and it's heartbreaking
because,
you know,
they had where they had some success for
a period of never recaptured it and
didn't reinvent themselves.
I noticed something really interesting
when I went to Australia for book tour
and I'm going back there,
uh,
and a couple of weeks,
which was amazing,
which is I did a lot of events with
really famous Australians who didn't
cross over to the US.
So like you have your ACDC that came
over here and just blew out bird,
you know,
Nicole mean fill in the blank.
But there was people who were like big
movie stars who didn't make it here.
I'm a big,
like an enormous rock band there that
just didn't make it to the US.
And the one thing that I was amazed with
is for some reason I came into contact
with them either for festivals or you
know,
we we had reading together is they all
had meaningful second slash third acts.
So this guy who was a big huge movie
star there was now a big crime fiction
reviewer,
so I met him because you just don't make
the sort of money and fame here and have
the kind of blown out at exposure that
you linger in and capture catch.
After the guy who was a songwriter for
one of the biggest rock bands in all of
us wrote it,
wrote this amazing memoir,
was like incredible and was working on
that.
And it's sorta like if you don't achieve
a sort of astronomical level of
exposure,
fame and money,
you still have to make a living.
And making a living is a really good
motivation to,
to continue to search for and find
meaning.
Great.
Yeah.
Well that's why.
Yeah,
that's one of the problems with having
wealth I think with regards to children
is that if you're wealthy you're
children can be deprived of necessity.
Right.
And they and also usually by the time
one his attained wealth.
You've sort of baked in the discipline
of your end,
the love for your field that led to us.
I mean I guess we can exclude people
that do a job that they hate forever,
but usually people who really make a lot
of money sort of love what they're doing
at some level I find.
And by the time you get to a point,
do you know what her after work,
you love the work so much and you start
to realize that the money once people
stopped chasing you for bills is what
brings you the happiness.
Because you couldn't take all the
shortcuts when you were younger.
Like trust fund kids can.
Yeah.
Well the,
the empirical evidence on that is pretty
clear.
Just give me one sec here.
There is a relationship between material
wellbeing and happiness,
roughly speaking or let's say wealth and
happiness up to the point where you're
basically in the lower middle class I
would say.
And that's basically the point where
bill collectors stopped chasing you
around.
There's definitely pain in privation,
but there isn't a tremendous amount of
advantage by,
by,
by the evidence in moving far up the
economic ladder beyond that,
and I think it's because money solves a
certain set of,
yeah problems,
but the ones that doesn't solve it
doesn't solve it all right?
She doesn't solve love that it doesn't
solve.
Ensuring that your children are doing
well.
It doesn't solve health.
Um,
in any final sense that the problem with
the oral health,
I was also thinking with regards to
perfection and intimacy,
there's another kind of opposition
between them,
which is that if you're after
perfection,
you can't have intimacy because you have
to.
You mentioned that we have this idea
that you shouldn't settle and people
often say that in relationship to their
relationships,
but they forget that the person that
you're having a relationship with has
settled for you.
And,
and
that means that they've settled for
imperfection in every sense of the word.
And you,
if you're after perfection in your
relationship,
then first of all,
you have impossible standards.
Second year,
impossible to live with.
And third,
if you meet someone that triggers that
ideal,
then you're going to feel so inferior in
relationship to them that you're going
to make a fool of yourself.
Now it's the classical animal,
randomness possession from the union
perspective,
you know,
you find someone who meets your ideal of
perfection and then you're so tongue
tied in their presence that you can't
help but act like a complete deer in the
headlights or something equally
pathological.
So to get into the scene you have to
give up that you have to give up that
demand,
at least for immediate perfection May.
Maybe you could work towards it within
the confines of the relationship.
But that's a whole different thing.
Well driller perspective,
I mean for me,
what was so interesting in building that
with Evan is
it's like he's trained as a lone wolf,
right?
There's an orphan program that kicked
out orphans,
but none of them know who each other is.
They operate alone,
but he's chosen to live in the middle of
this residential tower in the world
corridor.
Kind of hiding among people.
But so he's constantly among people.
But if he sticks to his normal routine,
which is just training,
he's got like a hidden vault that's like
as operations comm center that's hidden
in the back of his super modern
penthouse.
There's all these sort of fantasy
elements to it,
which I think I undercut enough to not
turn it into like sort of,
you know,
weapons foreign or spy car.
Like he,
like there's,
there's,
there's an awareness that,
that,
that I,
I roamed it,
Debbie,
even as I revel in some of these
archetypes,
but if he just sticks to his routine,
there is no one there to tell him or
point out his imperfections.
Right?
When he's on a mission,
it doesn't matter.
He's operating Solo.
He's kicking ass.
He has the righteousness and the moral,
the legitimate moral superiority of
doing what is the right thing in the
protection of other people.
That's all fine.
There's no one to literally gaze on
Hammer.
Even look at him and notice where his
imperfections are.
Notice where his tongue tied.
Notice what skills that there are that
he's lacking.
If his life stays in that narrow lane,
but he doesn't want his life to just be
in that lane,
but every time he widens it out,
there's all these complications where
it's like,
what do you do with an unruly eight year
old who's asking you inappropriate
questions?
These are things that his training
wasn't for.
And there's a real interest in that.
And one of the other things I wanted to
add as you talked about the,
the female or erotica or the or the that
women tend to read and the types of
monsters which I love that the surgeon
is included.
And um,
and you know,
I'm sure a lot of them can.
We can start combining them.
So you get like a werewolf surgeon.
You can really start upping the ante.
But I think one of the things that's
really interesting in terms of what
constitutes a successful balance to me,
it's not also the full teaming of the
monstrous of perfectionism.
Whether like in this instance we're
talking about that being from the male
side of it.
It's also like I had a question that was
I did an interview yesterday and
somebody asked me who knows,
who knows me and my wife pretty well,
and so does your wife get,
does she get upset when you're like,
okay honey,
I'm off to like the Mexican jungles to
go down class for a Whitewater rafts to
the researcher.
I'm going to go,
you know,
like I just was on a range in vegas
shooting a lot of insane weapon where
you're,
you know,
when,
when I'm,
when I'm doing these sort of more
dangerous elements that are for
research.
And it was interesting because I hadn't
been asked that that specifically,
but I was like,
well I would as a writer when I met my
wife and she liked that,
a new that and one of the primary themes
is if that's something that you liked in
me,
she,
that's the last thing.
She wants to erode it me now.
And we also have a relationship where
like obviously there's things like if
there are things about me that are
annoying to my perfectionism or need to
be reined in,
that's a good discussion.
But it also doesn't mean that you want
to hollow out the aspect of the,
of the perfectionist drive or the
aspects that involve sort of dangerous
with danger,
having one foot and monstrosity from
your spouse or partner in either
direction.
It's like,
you know,
my wife and I just genuinely like each
other.
We don't want to erode in each other.
Those things that caused the initial
attraction.
And it's interesting.
[inaudible],
I think that's something you see a lot
in marriages.
I don't know if it's particularly in
America where you get the sort of
domineering controlling wife and the
husband is like the little boy getting
away with things and you know,
trying to get things done and there's
this imbalance that happens really
quickly as they push each other into
these roles and forget the very things
that more attractive to begin with.
Yeah.
Well you see that,
you see that operating in the other
direction.
Although I would say in a different way,
because you can see husbands who punish
or failed to reward their wives for
being attractive.
Even though,
yeah,
the domineering husband.
Your,
you said something once that stuck with
me when I think someone was bragging
about how they never cleaned the house
or something or some such thing.
You said,
well,
if you turn your wife into a maid,
then you'll be married to a maid.
Yes.
I think it was toilets.
Actually.
I'm not the sort of guy who cleans the
toilets.
I think I said,
yeah,
you're the sort of guy who makes your
wife cleaned the toilets,
right?
Yeah.
Well that's the thing is that it's also
very difficult within a relationship to
continually reward your partner for the
traits that make them attractive because
that also makes them attractive to other
people and so if you're concerned in any
way about your fading attractiveness or
if you're jealous or resentful,
then you may come to punish your partner
for what makes them attractive and of
course that's.
That's daft because you'll also have
contempt for them and for you if,
if you get away with that,
but it happens a lot.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
it goes down to the.
We've had.
We've had this conversation before that
at the end of the day,
there are any,
there are no decisions that aren't
fundamentally moral.
There's no good decisions when you're
looking at something of like,
well,
this is 90 percent moral,
but 10 percent shady,
but I can reap huge financial reward.
It's like,
don't think you'll get away with it.
And likewise,
you know,
within a marriage,
if you have a spouse who you're
denigrating or you're concerned about
their attractiveness because of your own
insecurity and you haven't put that to
rest and you're unwilling to look at
that,
that will cost you.
You know,
I think about it a lot as pertains to
writing because I think a lot that the
qualities for me at least that didn't
make me a better writer or the same ones
that make me a better man and a better
human.
And it's not something that people talk
a lot about,
but a lot of it is,
you know,
if you're.
If I'm in a conversation,
it's like,
can I acknowledge what my shortcomings
are and what my flaws are?
Can I acknowledge and an argument what's
going on?
Can I pay attention to people enough to
recognize small moments of
vulnerabilities and to try to honor or
respect those?
Those are all the things in writing that
it make people connect to character.
you need to round out a character.
And I remember when I was like,
I started really young and had a lot of
luck early.
I started my first book.
I was 19.
I sold it out.
I think it was 22,
23 and you know,
there's stuff in there that's awful,
like no one should ever be accountable
for anything that they thought when they
were 19.
But you know,
I have a line in there where it's like
he was the best of the best,
you know,
about like an agent and it's like those
are the people we don't like.
You just feel like as I get older,
a lot of.
I put the characters are the times where
you say something out of a,
a more base instinct and then you feel
like shit about it.
Like that's something that makes you
relate to a character.
Like I did this thing and I said
something,
I reacted in anger.
I have a petty jealousy,
but that I'm aware of it.
I acted badly and I feel I feel badly
for it.
I wish I could've acted better.
But do you need to have the,
the,
you know,
the uh,
pretty you need to iris pretty wide
opening to,
to take that input in if you want to be
talented artists
because you're trying to capture all of
those things which means you have to
look at them in yourself,
not just another people.
It's something you see in good
comedians.
And I was watching Louis C K recently,
like he definitely goes too far quite
often.
And one of the things about Louis C,
k that's,
and you also see this as Sarah
Silverman.
I think we're either of them know
something will come into their hand and
they'll say it and they know perfectly
well that they've gone too far but
they're not going to not say it.
And then they have the good graces to be
like self disgusted.
I would say that they actually said it,
you know,
and Louis said it's a mix of self
disgust and enterprise.
Yeah,
exactly.
At the same time,
but I need Louis Ck has the good graces
to be embarrassed at least 20 percent of
the time for me and for good reason to
like the cinema in the airport.
Yeah,
no,
he's.
Yeah,
but I mean that it's a big part of it is
like if you want to shut down self
awareness,
everything shuts down.
So.
And we're talking about with aging,
we're talking about with marriage and
relationships,
but I'm also talking about if you
wanted,
if you actually want to engage in an
endeavor that is interesting,
whether that's writing or teaching or
being a psychologist or being.
I mean fill in the blank for anything
that you want to engage in,
in a way that's new and unique.
You better reflect,
you better think on yourself.
You better not armor yourself solely an
ideology,
right?
You better be able to maintain it.
It sort of openness to the world.
Even as you're learning,
you better not get too arrogant.
Like if you go down that checklist,
I find a lot of them really apply to my
writing and ways that,
that are,
that are more direct than I ever would
have thought would be the case.
I didn't start kind of thinking about
this till I was in my thirties,
which is also rather on the time that I
started becoming a better human,
um,
uh,
but you know,
to really think about like getting
caught short at times or engaging in
something where I'm so adamant that I'm
right about it.
And then reflecting on it afterwards and
realizing that I'm wrong.
And it's like there's so much fodder.
That's where all the gold is in writing.
That's where all those pieces are and
really paying attention to people and
not overlooking their own quiet everyday
tragedies and recognizing their everyday
triumphs because that's what rounds out
of character.
If you can capture that,
all of a sudden you feel like you're
reading something that's alive and if
you don't,
you're reading something that you feel
like is fill in the blanks.
You know?
And especially with with a forum like,
like a thriller,
Crime Fiction,
which I'm far from denigrating.
I think it's an incredible forum.
I think that's interesting too.
Is that you,
that's a form that you've stuck with in
many ways throughout your writing
career.
And that's been about 20,
20.
You have 23 books now.
I have a seven,
17 or 18 out maybe.
And three more than the pyre lot.
Okay.
So you've been basically putting out
something like a book a year.
Yeah.
So there's,
there's two places we could go with
that.
One is that I'd like to talk with you a
little bit about how you've actually
managed to have a successful career as a
writer because that's a very difficult
thing to pull off.
And the other issue is why you've,
you've inserted yourself in this very
limited form,
John Reform and I'm curious about why
that one and also what it is about the
genre and the fact that it's a very,
very commercial and very attractive in a
sort of,
I wouldn't say easy way,
but in a very accessible way.
It,
it's very accessible to people.
And so what's,
what's the attraction,
like why not?
It's something that's arguably more
literary.
Well I don't,
I mean the first thing is,
is it's like it's not selected.
Like I can only write stuff that I feel
in my gut that I need to write.
And fortunately for me from a financial
perspective that tends to be stuff that
that's highly commercial.
But you know,
one of the things I think about,
like for me,
the,
the gold standard is always hitchcock.
Like no one's like,
oh see commercial or was he a critical
six ass?
And what's interesting is,
you know,
you talked,
we talked about all this stuff that we
only see in hindsight,
like you follow only the things that are
of interest and then in hindsight they
all make sense.
So.
Right?
So in college I studied English and
psychology as you know,
you were there and I got really
fascinated with shakespearian tragedy in
particular and it's like,
okay,
so I'm studying young Ian,
analysis of Shakespearian tragedy.
All that is about narrative.
All of it is narrative.
I only chose it because I was
interested.
I got,
I was very into Freud,
you know,
those case studies.
We'd like short stories,
but.
So it's like,
let's take Shakespeare.
Okay,
so why would shakespeare choose this
form?
That is limited,
right?
Everything's got five back.
He basically wrote a highly convention
bound,
highly structured narrative driven form,
sometimes tipping into propaganda that
deals with last intriguing murderer
designed to sell out the most,
you know,
he's the most seats in the globe theater
to put asses in chairs.
He had no interest in enduring literary
value,
you know,
um,
a lot of people are interested in during
literary value,
don't enduring,
we don't tend to.
Enduro is another discussion,
but when you cut that glue,
yeah,
I,
you cut the globe theater and half and
it's a perfect cross section of
Elizabeth and society.
So I'll have a joke from audit to
metamorphosis and then he'll make a dick
joke for the groundlings.
He's trying to appeal everywhere.
And within the,
the,
within the constraints of the form,
there is a liberation.
So he takes the Jew of Malta in terms of
the merchant of Venice in very few
original plots.
Right.
And so there's this reworking of trying
to do something that's great within a
form that's recognizable,
but I think it's recognizable because
it's pleasingly archetypal and people
forget,
you know,
look,
this can movies.
The Stranger was,
was inspired by James and Keynes.
The Postman always rings twice,
like these forms are,
are,
you know,
you want to talk about existentialism.
You,
these chandler.
Oh yeah.
You know,
so there's an enormous amount and it's
been,
it's been said quite often that that
door is modern tragedy,
but instead of falling from the throne,
you're falling from the curb into the
gutter,
right?
You're just starting lower.
It's also been said the crime fiction
has replaced the social novel.
And if you look at,
um,
you know,
you look at like Mr wherever from Dennis
Lehane,
it's like that.
That's such an interesting story,
right?
You know,
I wrote a book called town allies takes
place in San Francisco that is built
around a thriller,
but it's all about class in society and
ethics in San Francisco.
And in a weird way for me,
when I'm playing with these notions of
intimacy versus perfection,
when I'm playing with this notion of a,
you know,
aging versus focus,
um,
the themes around humanity about being
better,
if I can wrap them in what I hope is an
enormously entertaining page turning
story that's propulsive that people want
to read.
That's the kind of thing that I most
enjoy and engage in that for me,
sort of the ultimate win.
I'm going to get to write about
everything that I want to write about in
as exciting and compelling fashion that
I can manage within the restraints of my
skill.
And I don't do that as having a ceiling.
You know,
I don't think anyone's going to come
along and go,
you know,
look,
mcbath pretty lacking on the,
on the quality scale,
you know,
you look at.
And so there's always an aim for it.
And also I just love thrillers,
you know,
instead of writing a thriller with more
meat on the bones where I'm really
stretching and there there's a number of
people to do it in the forum.
And so I,
I'm the only one,
um,
it's just a great,
it's a great focus and you know,
again,
if you don't focus on something,
where do you wind up?
And also look,
this goes back to narrative to
archetypal narrative too,
like I believe that there are
fundamentally fundamental story
structures and that our is selected for
as opposable thumbs and islands.
You know,
and I think
you'll find a tribe that's been,
you know,
in the middle of the Amazon,
the ted no exposure.
And we'll have eyelids,
opposable thumbs,
and a hero archetype.
This is the archetype.
Gilgamesh is a thriller.
You know,
Beowulf is a kick ass thriller.
That's what those things are.
And that's the form that just appeals to
me.
You know,
Moses,
the exodus is the thriller.
Yeah.
The Ta,
you know,
I look,
I collect faulkner paperbacks from the
fifties and they're insane.
Like they have these Harlequin type
covers,
you know,
like another from America's leading
purveyor of murder and lust.
William Faulkner,
I mean,
they were packaged as such,
but you read sanctuary with the
courtroom case and the corn cob.
I mean,
good God,
there's,
you know,
he's,
he's got,
he's up to his elbows and in Jordan
certain genre conventions as originally
went to Hollywood and adapted Chandler
novels.
Great.
You know,
so for me it's all about.
I mean he already slug away.
Yes.
Yeah.
Well then he also did the big sleep.
I want to say I need someone to freight
back checked out to make sure I got that
one right.
But,
you know,
I'm,
yeah,
that's true.
You know,
at the end of the data,
like I,
I am a structure slot.
I think structure is essential structure
slumped.
Watch me structure slut and fun and
that,
that'll be my website instead of young
women who are symmetrically perfect and
represent a particular gummy and ideal.
Um,
but I,
I feel like I like to know where I am
within a story.
You know,
I like to,
I'd like to know where the terms are.
I can,
I like to play with them lies with
Batman.
We talked about once you have the
conventions,
you can start to play with them.
You can start to find more elbow room
within them.
Yeah,
well that's a nice thing too is that
people often think about creative
freedom as the freedom for many
structural impositions whatsoever.
And that's,
that's the Peter Pan thing or what did
you call your character?
Castle.
Oh,
casserole casserole.
Yeah,
without obstruction.
And without limits,
you have freedom.
It's like you don't just have chaos.
Well,
and I have like,
you know,
having written all these novels and the
nowhere,
man,
there's one novel did something really.
I'm sorry,
there's one chapter that something
really bad happens to Evan and each
chapter in the orphan accent in the
Norman has a title that's taken from
something in the chapter,
usually a sort of humorous way that it
can be double rent,
but it's a phrase from the chapter as a
chapter heading.
And so one of the chapters after this
horrific thing happen to evan is just
cold and the whole chapter is just the
word cold.
That's the whole chapter.
So one more chapter and then you move
on.
So it's,
that's not conventional writing.
I'm not,
you know,
there's ways that you can start to play
once you're within it,
but you know,
I don't want to write in a whole,
you know,
book in Haiku and like the mass
experimentation or you know,
I wrote a book called a crime writer
where I literally,
it's a crime writer who lands on
something that's in the middle of
seemingly one of his own story.
He's a disaster situation and he
realizes that in order to understand
what happened,
he has to write it down.
So then I introduced a typewriter font.
That's the first sentence of the book
that we read or the first paragraph of
the book.
And then at a certain point his editor
comes in and has hand written edits in
the margins of the typewriter so that we
see the development process of the
writing,
which mirrors the process of his own
writing.
Which is the story of what happened to
him,
which has been all of that.
We're reading.
So there's all these ways that you can
play within the form to make an
interesting.
But at the end of the day,
I want to know where I am in a story.
That's what always appeals to me.
Great.
So look,
let's,
I'd like you to talk a little bit about,
about your career from a practical sense
too because you've been able to maintain
it for a long time.
So I think people would be interested to
know what your typical,
how you learn to write and what your
typical day looks like.
I don't know what we're passing like
across the last 20 years because one of
the strange things about being an
independent artist is that you don't
have those external constraints
precisely driving you the same way that
you do.
If you have to go to work everyday.
If you have to be up at nine for someone
else and it's very easy for people to
drift in a situation like that because
you can always put off what you have to
do until tomorrow.
Or You could also always substitute the
long,
medium,
or longer term ambition for something
short term that needs to be done right
now.
So let's start out by how you learn to
write.
I never did a writing course or read a
book on writing.
I mean,
how do you learn to write a novel,
you know,
2000 novels and then you try and write
one and screw it up.
That's it.
Same with screenplays,
you know,
watch a million movies.
Love the thing itself.
My first book,
I wrote a disastrous first draft.
I mean the,
the end of each chapter was better than
the beginning,
literally from what I've learned while
writing the chapter.
But again,
don't be afraid.
I've had two things that have benefited
me a lot.
One is I'm not afraid to fail,
I'm not afraid to embarrass myself.
Um,
and I also don't have any delay between
wanting to try something and trying it.
Like I don't hold back and wait and
think about it.
And I just was like,
I want to write a novel.
I'm 19.
I think I know more than I do.
I'm just going to jump in and do it.
I wrote it.
I had a really shitty first draft,
the vomit draft.
I sat down and took it apart like an
engine block and then I looked at it all
and reconstructed as,
what do you mean exactly?
It's kind of just kind of chapter by
chapter and like this plot isn't working
and this is two longest stretch without
action and this character developed
enough.
You know,
I took the chapters out and it felt like
I did it.
My first draft was half the length of
the final model.
Um,
it wasn't till my third novel that I
wrote a rough draft that could
constitute an awful on its own.
It's functioned.
Yeah.
So part of what you were doing was
separating the production end of the
process from the editing end.
I mean,
that's what,
that's what a bad first draft doses you
allow it.
Yeah.
And I,
you know,
and then as I get further along,
it's like I like my first draft now is
what my 10th draft used to be.
Right.
It keeps it,
it keeps sort of evolving,
but then know all,
try something new like orphan x.
I did more rewriting on than any of my
previous six books.
It still wasn't anywhere close to my
first,
you know,
three dolls,
but if I really was doing something new,
I was building an entire character and
entire mythology and launching this big
new franchise into the world.
And so in some ways I overrode it and
pull stuff back that I save for future
books.
I mean,
so I'd say that's one part of it.
The other is I think it might've been
advised you gave me when I was shadowing
or 18,
but you said when it comes to writing
and if you didn't say we can just
pretend that you did.
We'll give you credit for gambling.
I'm taking credit that then you leave
me.
If it's not wise,
then they'll be like Wiley,
coyote out over the cliff.
Just watch.
We all know.
But you said there's always going to be
a dozen things that are more pressing to
do then.
Right.
Always.
And if you don't decide to make that
time sort of holy and protected,
nobody else will do that for you.
And that's essential.
And I was already kind of into my first
book and doing it and I thought that's
exactly right.
Like it's always more pressing to clean
the house or pick up your dry cleaning
or you know,
pick up one of your kids if you don't
just carve it out.
It's not like I'm a surgeon,
I'm in an office,
one of those monster surgeons where I'm
in an office and no one can reach me.
And my day is sad.
I mean at any time right now I could be
disturbed all the time by anyone.
My phone can ring.
So unless I say this is my writing
schedule,
I'm unplugged,
you know,
kids leave me alone unless someone is on
fire or the house is on fire and it is
us.
I need the same amount of space that I
would have Brian Accountant or a
psychologist or you know,
a doctor or a lawyer,
you know.
And so I had to make that time kind of
holy are sacrosanct.
And then I would say the other thing is
that mattered a lot is I realized early
on that the one thing I'll say,
there's two other pieces that I'll say.
The one thing that I could control
absolutely was discipline.
That's the only controllable thing and
it's such an impossible field and so you
have to wait for luck.
And I had a lot of luck early,
which I don't say with false humility or
fishing for compliments.
Like my first book was good and I think
it was sellable and there's a lot of
first books that good in sellable.
You never know when that luck's going to
come.
And I thought in sort of work ethics,
if I flap my wings as hard as I could
that I'm just bumping along the ceiling
all the time.
The one moment that that hatch opens,
that the lucky break comes,
I was going to be right there to fly
through it.
And so from day one I was like,
I'm going full speed all the way no
matter what.
And I still do.
I mean,
I still feel like the one thing I can
control is I've never been late on a
deadline,
you know,
and I write all day every day I built it
up like a muscle.
So how much time do you spend writing in
a date now?
At minimum I write from six to 4:30
or five on laundry days.
If I'm on deadline or if I'm near the
end of a book and I can smell it,
it will be 13,
14,
15,
sometimes 16 hours.
And I've had spells of,
like I said,
I once wrote a script for a TV show and
1:23
hours sitting because there was a risk
that a micro economy in Vancouver would
shut down if I did it.
If there's a shutdown,
the show,
it's problematic.
So I can go when I go.
But at a minimum I'm writing all day
every day,
you know,
with a break to work out in the middle.
And the other thing I'd say is really
interesting is like,
you know,
it's funny seeing which values get.
So people look at my resume and I went
to all these fancy schools and people
always ask me like they asked me about
Shakespeare,
the throughout my educational
background.
Okay.
You studied English and here you went
and did a masters in England.
I think in some ways one of the biggest
values for me was being was came from
being an athlete because I was a pole
vaulter in college.
Right.
I played soccer growing up.
I played soccer in England and writing
is like training.
It's like working out.
It's building a muscle.
And as with pole vaulting when I was
training day 27,
when the heptathlon will championships
were on day 275,
I have 100 things more important to do
than train on day 27 and know that I
have to go that far.
That's like a 27 or writing a novel,
you know.
And so there's a lot of,
I think people undervalue the value
sports now for health and for,
you know,
being active and being well rounded,
but we don't tend to talk about the
values that they instill and a lot of
like discipline,
longterm planning,
you know,
like I,
when I was in high school I sucked at
pole vaulting.
I mean my whole first year I was too
small to bend the pole.
Sophomore year it was awful.
And we're talking to is a three year
process to build up to start jumping at
a high level and eventually,
you know,
at a national level and then in college.
But it takes a lot of discipline.
And so there's the discipline aspect of
writing I think is really important.
And then,
you know,
for people starting out,
one of the things I say is like,
pick a certain amount of time that you
do no matter what and force yourself to
get stuff on the page.
And if you say all I could find is an
hour day or two hours a day,
uh,
or I'm sorry,
two hours,
twice a week.
That will soon turn into two hours and
15 minutes or two hours and two and a
half hours.
It will expand itself as your discipline
goes on.
It's like running and the other thing I
say is that,
look,
I mean a lot of people who want to be
writers and I meet very few who actually
want to write.
I love writing.
I actually loved the writing process.
If you don't,
don't do this.
There's a million other things you can
do and make more money and it's easier
and you can be happier.
And when you say you love it,
what do you mean exactly?
I mean that doesn't mean it's easy by
any stretch of the imagination.
What does it mean exactly?
What do you mean by that?
Well,
it's,
it's the one place I really clearly lose
time.
You know,
when things are going well,
an hour and a half,
two hours will pass.
That happens to me when I'm on the
soccer field.
Two is like I just,
I feel fully inhabited in something else
aside from me in a manner that is
productive and I feel like I don't.
I'm not one for getting precious about
writing with beckoning menus and
whatnot,
but like there's an ask,
there's a part of pleasure.
I have these really loud keyboards that
I hammer on.
I've a whole broken slu or keyboards
that I've gone through.
I feel like a carpenter,
I feel like I'm pounding and hammering
and cutting and pasting and I liked the
keyboard to be really loud so then it's
a muscular action and I just feel
utterly engaged and fascinated in what
in this world that like I'm in control,
but there's endless opportunities and my
job is to be open to opportunity while
also making sure that I'm kind of
steering the ship and there's an
enormous amount of responsibility and at
the same time I'm living in a world of
my own making and holy alone.
So first let's hear your keyboard.
Yeah,
you just like the 19 thirties newsroom
or if my friends joke with me about as
the.
When they're on the phone and if I'm
rude enough to be writing or finishing a
sentence there would say you sound like
the asshole travel agent where they
can't move your flight.
We're like,
okay,
so Dallas has shut down.
Can I go through Chicago?
No,
I'm terribly sorry.
Can Be an issue.
Can we get me?
No,
I'm sorry.
Your flight's been delayed six hours.
I mean it's still loud.
Old fashioned angry travel agent
keyboard.
Right,
right.
It's very funny.
So.
So your toe.
Yeah.
So you talked about discipline and you
talked about responsibility.
When you're writing,
like what do you mean by that exactly?
Well,
your ego is constantly subservient to
the plot,
so to write,
well you come up with a basic set of
tenants that start your story.
It's like,
it's,
it's like,
it's so complex.
It's like,
it's like surfing,
like there's so many factors.
So when people are like,
you know,
there's,
there's sort of like the idiot criticism
of certain movies like you know,
passenger,
57,
you remember where Wesley Snipes is the
super bad ass Spec ops guy on the
airplane that gets hijacked and some
people are like,
well what are the odds that you'd be on
plane that got hijacked?
And you're like,
well,
it's 100 percent because no one wants to
write a story about the other 99,000,
999 times that a plane got hijacked and
passenger 57 wasn't on it.
Like that's why we're writing this
story.
So you have a unique set of
circumstances that can involve,
that can involve coincidence at the
outset.
That's first act stuff,
right?
So,
okay,
this is a story about the one time that
an orphan who was taken out of her
program at the age of 12 and trained to
be an assassin,
you know,
left the program because his moral
compass was broken.
And that's his story.
It's like whatever you think the odds of
that are,
that's the narrative contract.
That's what I'm doing and I can't
introduce them in the third act of a
realism based mystery.
That's a drawing room,
Mr.
that takes place in Vermont.
So we set the course of that.
Right.
Okay.
So that's the contract with the
narrative contract and the contract with
the reader.
You don't get to break.
You say,
look,
give me leeway while I set this up.
Yeah.
Here's the coincidence,
the coincidence,
or here's the unlikely set of
circumstances that are why I have
decided to sit down at my type
typewriter sounding keyboard and
devoting your life to this.
Okay,
so we're all in on that.
Then you round out your characters and
what you want us to give them freedom.
But you're also steering like,
I don't believe all this stuff that
like,
you know,
oh my gosh,
I just start to channel everything and
it's magic.
Like you're controlling it.
But when I'm writing,
well,
I have characters who are wittier than I
am in real time.
Not Meaning,
like one of the things that's great with
writing books is that a year later,
go back with the perfect comeback to,
uh,
you know,
like I have a year to come up with and
polished the dialogue.
And that's great.
So whenever you've been in a party and
someone slights here when you're driving
home going,
oh,
I shouldn't have said that.
We get to say that when we're writing.
But I've had that happen in real time.
So there's something that starts to go
on with characters as you engage in them
that they're doing stuff that I feel
like I'm typing just behind it
happening,
like it's just moving and that's a great
feeling and there's this really weird
thing that you want to get to,
which is by the end of a book,
the conclusion should feel at once
inevitable and unpredictable.
So you want to have things happen and
we've all had that.
I don't know if some people had it with
the success some people had it with.
We've all had that feeling in a movie or
reading a book where you're right on the
lip of discovery and then the thing
happens and you're like,
oh my God,
that makes so much sense and completely
caught me off guard at the same time.
That's the win,
right?
And so you need to sort of.
You have a responsibility to always make
your needs subservient to the plot.
Like the story is paramount.
And so as much as you're the creator,
you have to give free will to the story.
You have to give stuff up that you don't
and wouldn't otherwise.
I might have spent weeks research on
something
if it doesn't fit the story per our
properly,
I have to,
you know,
they,
they call it killing your babies,
right?
You have to get rid of it,
you got to throw it out and you have to.
It's really useful for,
I think,
beginning writers to know that we
touched on previously,
which is that yeah,
you have to be willing to throw things
away.
Lots of things.
I mean what I do to kind of take the
sting out of that to some degree is I
always have a document open on my
computer called Kols and I'll pull out a
paragraph that doesn't fit and throw it
in there and you know,
there's always the possibility that I'll
find a place for it later.
But often I do something with it later
too.
So the writing is necessarily.
But yeah.
Well,
and you know,
so you're,
you're trying to make everything work
and you're trying to be surprising at
the same time.
But also you have to be open to
opportunity.
And I,
I had my third book in particular learn
this because I got all the way to the
end and the ending that I thought was
the exact opposite of the ending of the
story that I had created and I realized
I had a choice.
I can either honor the story that I've
created and,
and make this thing that's better and
surprising and unplanned for.
Or I can write propaganda,
I can see purpose story to my own means.
And like that's like,
that's an brand,
right?
It's like there's never going to be a
shocking reveal where they're,
you know,
in an an brand,
you know what it is and she's filling it
out.
You know what all of her thoughts are.
So the writing for is in a process of
discovery necessarily.
It's a process of furthering the set of
philosophical points
she does.
That's second rate,
I think is that all her heroes and all
her villains,
like all her heroes are the same hero
and all her villains are the same
villain.
And all the villains are completely
villainous.
And all the heroes are completely
heroic.
Well,
snaps.
Propaganda.
Yes,
yes.
Well,
it's exactly the opposite of Dostoevsky,
you know,
where he makes his,
his villains are more heroic than his
heroes by a substantial margin he makes
superman to,
to,
to argue against fundamentally.
Right.
And so,
you know,
one is about being open and the other
thing I would say with writers is I see
a lot here who were,
you know,
and this is true for,
fill in the blank for artistic feel and
a lot of people who were like,
you know,
I went to beverly hills high,
I studied screenwriting Undergrad,
I got a masters in screenwriting and
here I go and I'm ready to go and I want
to write.
And you're like,
well,
what the hell are you going to write
about?
You know,
a lot of people.
I think having a broad range of life
experiences important.
You know,
there's some of the writers who I admire
the most.
Like James Ellroy was like borderline
homeless,
not homeless for awhile,
just knocking about and figuring stuff
out and on jobs and like living out in
the world.
And so if you want to write this or,
or,
or create some sort of constructed
amalgam of previous things that have
been constructed,
go all the way through all the course
work and do all that.
But it,
it,
it's huge benefit to just pursue
anything that interests
you because looking back it makes sense.
I don't know why I chose young,
you know,
and looking in hindsight it's like,
well no shit,
right?
He didn't write about anything but
storytelling,
but I didn't choose him in some way.
And I remember even in college,
so I was an English and psychology,
but like I,
I sort of wanted to,
you know,
I took a course in opera and I took a
course in classical music.
I mean,
which I have zero aptitude for music,
but I really was,
you know,
in,
in art and all these different arenas to
just have at least have a basis of
things to write about.
And I think the same is true for life
experiences.
Like do it,
a lot of stuff do stuff that's
dangerous,
you know?
So let's.
Okay,
so we should fill in a backstory here
for people too,
because I imagine there are somewhat
curious,
I mean I've known you for a long time.
We met when you were a student at
Harvard when I was teaching there and
you're actually the only one of the
undergraduates that I knew there that
I've kept up a relationship with over
this protracted period of time,
um,
for,
for a variety of reasons,
but it's not like I didn't meet all
sorts of remarkable undergraduates
there.
But um,
do you,
uh,
do you have any particular memories of
that period of time when we were
interacting?
I can certainly tell one story,
but I'll see what you come up with
first.
Well,
I remember you were,
I remember you were formal in a way that
I respected that because I still
remember we were,
we were friends or seeing each other
outside of school for like four years
before I finally was like,
is it okay if I call you Jordan instead
of Dr Peter said,
and I think that the,
the,
the formals,
maybe the wrong word,
you,
you had a certain authority that I think
was key to the teaching process and you
didn't Brooke Fools,
I'm an all like if someone came in with
an argument from either end of the
spectrum,
uh,
from an ideological perspective,
you had no interest in us.
And so that was really palatable for me.
And then I think what happened with,
with young was that I like,
I just sort of fell in love with all of
that for like,
that just,
it,
it's weird how much our interests
aligned along those fronts because I had
been very interested obviously in
storytelling and thrillers and all this
stuff,
but dealing with young and dealing with
the shadow.
We encountered some early political
correctness there together.
If I remember correctly,
because you were in the English
department and you were studying
Shakespeare and you wanted to study
Shakespeare from a union perspective,
and if I remember correctly,
at that time Shakespeare wasn't exactly
popular in the English department and,
and you was,
um,
well,
Nazi.
Yeah,
exactly.
The very opposite of popular.
So that was also very interesting.
Yeah.
Well when I was hitting a lot of that
though,
I think it wasn't,
it didn't feel like it was the pitch
that it was now,
but it was at a sort of nineties were.
And it also felt kind of more
interesting where like,
it felt more conversational,
a weird way.
Like where people.
Like I had my favorite feminist,
like I was like,
I really liked Naomi Wolf.
Like someone,
what she says really makes sense to me.
Like there was conversations about stuff
in a way that felt different and
there's,
there's sort of this rigidity now with
people snapping to both sides of the
equation.
But I mean,
I think one of the things that I,
you know,
in our courses that I liked a lot was
that if somebody raised something that
was clearly just some ideologically
based,
here's what I'm supposed to be saying
and reiterating,
you wouldn't have any tolerance for us.
And I always respected that because it
was like,
and it also wasn't from a perspective of
being shut down to it.
It was like,
I love eating conversation that you want
to have on the merits,
but I'm not going to engage in a
conversation with a false bit of
scaffolding that you're inhabiting.
It was sort of the vibe.
So that was interesting.
Um,
so I written there.
The thing I remember,
one of the things I remember was,
and I'm sure you remember this too,
is that in one of my personality
classes,
I had asked the questions for a scale
called the sensation seeking scale,
which was what of the early versions of
a big five variant and to sensation
seeking scale asks people in park about
minor juvenile rule breaking.
I think shoplifting might've been one of
the many ways.
And so I asked everyone questions and I
had them score it and then I asked
people to put up their hands at each
level of increase in scores,
like are you in the bottom 10th
percentile percentile,
the 10th percentile or whatever.
And if I remember correctly,
you were the only person who put up his
hand in the highest of the categories.
And if I also remember correctly,
I laughed about that quite a bit.
And then if I also remembered correctly,
you got a date out of that.
Yeah.
Somebody asked me who is either like the
top percentile in sensation seeking or
where will surgeon it was going to be
pretty much,
I pretty much hit it,
but we should also keep in mind that
this was at Harvard.
And so like the skills for like crazy
sensation seeking daredevils,
you know,
one of the things that's going to be
surprised about when I,
when I administered that scale to the
whole class was just how low the overall
scores were.
And we know that conscientiousness is a
really good predictor of,
of academic performance.
And so I would say that,
you know,
the kids there tended towards hyper
conscientious miss more than towards say
entrepreneurial,
the entrepreneurial sort of thing.
It's like if you want the wind,
like we're talking about this from the
big five,
it's like obviously conscientiousness,
better predictor in some ways than Iq,
right?
On the street scale.
But it's like if you can have the talent
and conscientiousness,
that's where you see people killing it
in like three or four
shows.
I mean like that's just a win.
And so,
you know,
one,
it's rare to have that entrepreneurial
artistic,
creative ability and also to ally that
with say industriousness,
which is part of conscientiousness.
And it's rough too because the
orderliness part of conscientiousness
scenes to constrain creativity.
So there's a real big mean.
One of the things we found,
for example,
is that on the political continuum,
imagine that that runs from,
from left liberal to conservative,
something like that.
The fundamental one,
the conservatives are high in
conscientiousness and low and
creativity,
but mostly what they're high end these
orderliness.
Whereas liberals are high in openness
and low in orderliness.
I'm one of the things that comes out of
that that's really interesting is that
I've been thinking a lot about lately is
I've been trying to figure out why
conscientiousness and openness aren't
correlated,
so there's no real reason for them to
lay together to predict political
temperament.
But one of the things that struck me
really hard and I think trump's
discussion of the wall between the US
and Mexico really got this active in my
mind,
was that as well as all this stuff I've
been involved in recently with regards
to what you can say and what you can say
and and,
and that kind of political correctness,
is that I think the fundamental
political question boils down to whether
borders should be opened or closed and
high orderly,
low creative people like everything to
be in boxes and they don't get much of a
kick out of the potential creative
interplay that can come from loosening
the borders between things.
But they're also willing to subject
themselves to the discipline of order.
So that's one of the things that gives
them an advantage.
But on the other side of the spectrum
with them
willing.
Yeah,
there is.
They wouldn't think that up.
It's like,
oh look,
there's a wall.
I better turn around to go home.
Well we could put a ladder over it.
How would that work?
Or.
Yes,
yes.
That's,
that's different.
The underground.
Yes,
yes,
exactly.
Well,
and so the liberal types they like,
they like to uh,
take advantage of the possibilities that
are set forth by breaking the borders
between things,
but they're also unwilling to accept the
discipline that working within an
orderly structure will,
will provide anyways.
I think the border issue is pervasive at
every level of analysis.
So the conservative types like the
borders around everything to remain
tight,
sexuality,
identity,
nationality that the state itself,
whereas the more
conventionally right now with trump and
advocate,
but conventionally conservatives are
returned even though Clinton cooperative
with like when it comes to money,
it's sort of like only rules around
maximizing money because free trade,
I
know that it's a funny one.
I mean you never get a pure
manifestation of these things.
I mean conservatives can be
protectionists too at times.
Right?
You know?
So I guess the political expression
depends to some degree on what's
happening in the environment at that
particular point.
But Surf,
surfing all these walls is like.
I mean that's the trick,
right?
It's so much easier to armor yourself
and one pure ideology.
You know,
one of the things I think about a lot is
with the skin,
so I've just gotten back from a two week
for a two week leg of the tour.
I'm in a different city every day and
it's like it's reviews and it's readers
and it's all the stuff.
And I've been thinking a lot about how
much work it takes to,
not to stay open creatively but stay
focused enough.
I'm pretty high in orderliness.
That's something that,
that,
that can interfere.
But it's weird because,
I mean,
one of the things I think about,
it's like to be a writer,
you sort of need the sensitivity of a
butterfly with the hide of a rhinoceros.
Like you need to be so sensitive and
attuned to things and also so willing to
accept,
you know,
rejection or negative reviews are all
kinds of weird feedback and everything
else.
And I'm saying this from someone who's
been fortunate enough to be largely
successful,
but it's still there.
There's a,
there's a battering that you take when
you try and advance something outside
the normal structure.
So you're starting to sound like
Madonna.
Oh,
I actually watched that speech she made
the other day and I think she's
depressed actually.
What was the speech?
What did I say that sounded like Madonna
oven of the year award or something like
that.
I happened to watch a version of it
where she was intercut with Milo
Yiannopoulos,
which was actually quite comical.
But uh,
she spent a lot of time complaining
about how hard it was to be Madonna and
to be a woman.
And I was watching it very carefully
because she,
she didn't say one positive thing about
her life and I thought and she seemed to
be close to tears most of the time.
And I thought there's something wrong.
She looked,
she looked at me like she was actually
depressed because it was,
you know,
I mean,
she's had a pretty successful go of it.
And to only focus on the negative is,
is,
is kind of rough,
so,
but neither of those things are bad that
I'm,
that I'm pointing to meaning like you
want to be as sensitive as possible so
that you're attuned to constant kept
this whole butterfly Rhinoceros Eminence
image.
It's like,
yeah,
I can see what I mean is there's a,
there's a trick to trying to be floating
to maintain all your openness and also
be tough as hell like that.
That's sort of one of the ways to do it
because you need to blaze forward with
it,
with it like butterfly Rhinoceros
blazing forward.
Exactly.
Yeah,
exactly.
Yeah.
As,
as the common refrain is socrates said,
a butterfly sting like a rhinoceros,
but when you're breaking away from those
structures,
those structures,
when you're in a space that's
entrepreneurial,
that's the chow.
I mean,
look,
that's part of the challenge that we're
seeing people not resisting with group
thing.
Like there's such a need to apparel and
armor yourself in inset ideologies,
you know,
and,
and to,
to have things be a certain way,
to just go all the way off on
orderliness.
But to try and maintain high discipline,
I orderliness and high opendesk the.
There's a constant tension that's
moving.
Yep.
Yeah.
Well,
I think that that's partly why high
level creative performances so rare is
because it's very difficult to bring
those things together because they
actually.
They're mutually constraining.
Well,
I think that's interesting.
For me,
I've worked with a lot of celebrities
who are at a fairly high level in the
highest level,
let's just say whether it's acting or
singing or household name people who,
some of whom carry with it.
The press reputation of being smart and
some who do not.
The one thing that always amazes me is
like anyone at a certain level of fame,
how has the level of unbelievable.
I'm sharpness,
like there's no one who accidentally
stumbled their way all the way up to
having a top 10 hit or a number one
movie or something else.
It's very,
very rare.
And so even people that we look at and
go,
that's some stupid celebrity.
That's a dumb actor,
that's an idiot singer.
People are running empires,
you know?
And they somehow have to do that while
keeping their antenna up and focused
and,
and letting enough end to keep creating
in a way that's meaningful.
Um,
it's,
I've yet to meet someone.
There's a lot of people who are a pain
in the ass,
but I've yet to meet people at that
level.
I'm not impressed.
One of the things I've learned in recent
years is to go watch famous people when
they come to Toronto,
no matter whether or not I like the.
So for example,
I went and saw Dolly Parton with my wife
about six months ago outside at the
amphitheater.
And like,
I wouldn't say I'm a great fan of Dolly
Parton's music.
I mean,
she's quite the phenomenon,
but,
but she was absolutely amazing.
Absolutely amazing,
brilliant,
witty,
self denigrating,
a incredibly musically talented,
a really engaging with the audience.
She really seemed to like to be there.
It was a real treat.
And,
and I agree with what you said,
is that it's a rare person who,
especially who manages to sustain that
across any amount of time who doesn't
have something truly remarkable about
them.
I'd also like to point out my
magnanimity of not taking the open
revenge shot through your Madonna
comment about you go into a Dolly Parton
concert.
I just want,
I just want that knowledge and let the
record show that I'm showing enormous
restricted at this point.
And you have the entire discussing.
I'm very.
I'm very happy about that too,
right?
Yeah.
Have a movie coming out in June.
You want to talk a little bit about
that?
It's called the book of Henry.
Um,
and it stars Naomi Watts.
We are Jacob Tremblay in it.
He's the boy from room.
Sarah Silverman,
who we mentioned earlier.
Dean Norris.
Terrific cast.
I'm Maddie Ziegler who is amazing gate
and leaving hers,
the boy from St Vincent and midnight
special and it's about I'm constraint
because we have a very kind of under
wraps.
We want it to be a surprise.
It's a very unusual,
very special kind of film.
I wrote the rough draft of this,
the first draft 18 years ago.
I,
this script has literally grown up with
me.
Um,
and I,
it's,
it's about a single mom.
Naomi Watts plays the character who is
raising two boys,
one of whom is a prodigy and something
very bad is happening next door to them
and working with her son who was a
prodigy,
she has to figure out she's a lot like
the child in the relationship and the 12
year old is more like the adults and
they have to sort of navigate through
their way to a solution.
It has a very strong thriller elements.
It has some humor.
I mean,
one of the things I said I was thinking
about is that I hope there's a lot of
emotions in it that will catch people
off guard.
Um,
and how it got made,
why it took so long to get made is it
was so unusual.
How it got made was I found a director,
I'm off a movie called safety,
not guaranteed that it's a wonderful
little small independent movie called
Colin trevorrow.
And we were moving forward toward
production.
And then he said,
look,
I just had a meeting with Spielberg.
There's no conceivable way he would give
me Jurassic world off my tiny little
movie that costs probably less than the
catering budget for Jurassic world,
but I just want to give you a heads up
on two weeks later he called and was
like,
dude,
I got dress mortal.
And so I lost him and he said to me,
you never know.
Maybe that will reveal,
you know,
make all this money,
we can just come back and get this
screen less.
Um,
and so he went off and made it,
you know,
maybe I think one point $7,000,000,000
for universal and true to his word.
And I have enormous regard for calling
for a variety of reasons,
but,
but this being one of them,
you know,
he came back and called me and said,
well now I'm doing one of the next star
wars movies and I have a window and
let's shoot this thing and go.
And so we had the small window.
I did,
I did the rewrite in like four or five
days,
the production or garage.
And we just,
he casts it like that.
I mean,
at that point he was someone who
everyone wanted to work with and off we
went and it was amazing.
It was like,
you know,
18 years later,
an overnight success.
Cool.
So yeah,
that was good.
Great.
We should probably call it quits.
I think it's been about 90 minutes,
which seems to be about the right amount
of time,
so thanks very much for talking with me
and uh,
well we'll talk soon and we'll see how
this goes as a youtube video and as a
podcast.
So I think you'll be the first one up on
the.
I'm going to hopefully do a number of
interviews.
I interviewed a Canadian composer
yesterday for 90 minutes as well,
but I think that one's going to take a
little time to get the audio editing
right.
So you might be the first one out,
so obviously I'll let you know as soon
as possible.
Thanks very much for taking an hour and
a half today.
Yeah,
thanks.
Thanks
for doing it.
This was great.
All right,
talk soon.
Bye.